the hardest thing is to come back after
three months of not doing any work not
doing any homework and all of a sudden
you got a lot to make everybody has a
lot to catch up on what the end of the
last year
so don't take it from us just take it
from him so it's back to reality for
President Biden the commander-in-chief
relating with some students heading back
to school as he himself confronts the
harsh reality of working after a
vacation-filled summer Biden is facing a
slew of problems in the country and a
long road ahead for his 2024 campaign
and it probably doesn't help that Bernie
Sanders is throwing some serious shade
at his record in New Hampshire pointing
out how Americans are suffering under
his presidency
the president has a right to be very
proud of many of the accomplishments
that we've achieved in the last three
years but
the reality is that today
60 percent of our people living paycheck
to paycheck our Health Care system is a
total disaster 85 million people
uninsured uninsured underinsured while
the insurance companies make huge
profits the cost of pharmaceutical drugs
prescription drugs Sky High
Bernie not stopping there the Socialist
Senator wading into the issue over
Biden's Advanced age and Republican
candidate Nikki Haley is warning that a
vote for Biden is a vote for Kamala
uh I you know met with the president I
don't know five or six weeks ago we had
a great discussion he seemed fine to me
but I think at the end of the day what
we have got to ask ourselves is what do
people stand for so age is an issue
Chuck but there are a lot of broader
issues than just that we cannot have
Kamala Harris as President we can't
chance the we have to make sure we win
this because the thought of Kamala
Harris being president should send a
chill up every American Spine this is a
new poll reveals a wide majority of
Americans view Biden as too old for
office 77 percent of people actually so
Harold is Bernie the answer to Biden's
problems up in New Hampshire they wanted
him to go up there and help him out he
maybe it's good to be back around the
table hope everybody had a good weekend
Nate a couple things I'd say about this
spoiler alert
we've had income inequality for a long
time in the country and unfortunately
over an overwhelming majority of America
of Americans have been living paycheck
to paycheck now for a generation in fact
most Americans could not withstand a 500
jolt Interruption emergency to their
family budgets as we all know now this
is not to let anybody off the hook
presidential race is at their best
are when both sides are even in a
primary people give specifics ideas of
vision but how they're going to solve
these problems how we're going to go
about dealing with them uh I'm not I
don't miss Bernie Sanders voice on the
national stage admittedly however I do
miss his energy and for him to say to
President Biden to remind him as you go
into an election season you can't rest
on your laurels we have invested in
building things here in America we have
invested in trying to de-risk us from
China but if we don't deal with what
Oliver Anthony deals with in that song
If we don't speak to the fact that
everyday Americans are concerned and
worried about their children their
neighborhoods their communities their
families Futures their own livelihood at
work then we're not being honest about
what presidential races are about so if
I were President Biden I'd listen to
Senator Senator Senator uh Sanders take
him at his word and begin to develop
specifics about how you're going to make
America stronger and help us get along
better over the next four years judge I
don't even know if you could get 77
percent of Americans to agree on a
Mother's Day resolution
you can get 77 of Americans to say
and I don't think they're saying it in a
way that is supposed to be mean towards
Joe Biden but that they are concerned
they said he is at this age he'll be the
oldest president if he were to win
re-election maybe 86 at the end of a
second term and they're saying this is
just too old I don't know how the White
House spends that
um well you know I think that they're
not worried about it because they
believe that people hate Donald Trump so
much and it appears that he's going to
be the Republican candidate the
Republican nominee based upon what we've
seen so far that they're willing to put
him up because they believe that he can
beat Donald Trump it's as simple as that
they hate him Donald Trump more than
they love the country and let me say
something interesting I thought the way
he answered the question
um you know about Joe Biden he said he
seemed fine to me right so he wasn't
discrediting the people uh who
questioned his Acuity and the
interesting thing is Bernie Sanders is
81 and you look at Bernie Sanders you
listen to me he's got his stuff together
Joe Biden is not about age he's about
mental acuity Joe Biden is about a guy
who's got some real problems walking and
tripping and and not knowing where he is
um but the the interesting part of this
also is when he said the hardest thing
to do is to come back after three months
to the kids on the first day of school
have not having done any work I mean I
don't know if he feels the same way I
think he's speaking from personal
experience he seems to have been on
vacation for uh the whole summer yeah at
the beach house and I just want to say
one thing the paycheck to paycheck thing
70 of people in urban areas are living
paycheck to paycheck most of the large
urban areas are Democrat areas so you
know that they're concerned about it
more than the average who apparently
it's 60 percent so they're not worried
about that they just hate Donald Trump
do you think Jesse that Bernie sees
Gavin Newsom out there and thinks
don't don't count me out
no he was just invited to speak at this
college in New Hampshire and said yes
I don't see any behind the scenes
jockeying
I can't believe that student was so
embarrassed to be seen with President
Biden that she asked us to pixelate her
face but that should that should that
should tell you everything you need to
know about the president's popularity we
have been living paycheck to paycheck
forever
the whole country has the whole world
lives paycheck to paycheck I was living
paycheck to paycheck well into my 30s
it's not the government's fault people
are living paycheck to paycheck this
country's run on consumer spending and
debt credit card debt mortgage debts
spend spend spend spend spend
we don't save we don't invest we're
purposely not taught to save and invest
I wasn't taught to save and investor a
couple years ago they don't want us
saving investing they know they want us
spending and putting it on the plastic
so Bernie to say that the government is
going to get us out of this paycheck to
paycheck that's impossible Bernie should
start speaking directly to the American
people and to say that oh my God the
these these insurance companies are
making so much money why doesn't Bernie
go after big food and big Tech
everybody's fat and sick because they're
staring at screens and eating toxic
stuff why doesn't he never talk about
that it's not the insurance companies he
said something interesting and I think
it should be a warning to the Republican
Party he said progressives aren't
challenging Joe Biden because Donald
Trump is such a threat the party has to
be United
Joe Biden's a threat so Republicans they
need to get together now Trump
Republicans shouldn't be trying to purge
other Republicans out of the party and
vice versa this Republican party needs
to grow it needs to go peel off
Democrats it needs to bring out new
voters it needs to get some Independence
it needs to build and expand the party
you need to win this thing in a
landslide and you're only going to win
it at a landslide unless the party grows
you sound like a different Jesse
before the end of the block and I'll
give you a chance to talk about anything
you want but we haven't touched on the
idea of the Republicans running against
Kamala Harris and I wonder about that
strategy well I think that that might be
part of the reason that we don't see her
that often because it's actually hard
enough to run against Joe and like you
said to challenge Joe because of his
weakness right it's hard to be that week
that it's also almost kind of a strength
because some of the stuff that he talks
about Judge like you pointed out it's
not really an age thing I mean I saw
Paul McCartney in concert who's older
than Joe Biden three hour show he's
singing he's playing all these
instruments Martha Stewart also older
than Joe Biden but how do you challenge
a guy who's just gets up there and he's
babbling about you know I was raised by
Puerto Ricans or shaking hands with the
air or calling out for dead people it's
a lot harder to challenge someone on
substantive policy issues when you can't
really put him in front of a group of
people and start to feel like wait where
am I where it could become confusing to
you so it is difficult to challenge him
and then it's difficult also to
challenge Kamala because what will we
challenge her on she never goes out and
she never says anything she never does
anything they don't do any interviews so
there's really there's nothing
substantive to argue against because
they don't really give people that
opportunity which they they should I
mean we should have access access to
that absolutely and then even this week
you just ignored questions
but we expect that right we're just like
oh that's just joking which is crazy if
I sat here and I started babbling on and
on I wouldn't make it to the next
commercial gym they would haul me out of
here well we would we would prevent that
from happening you would not get held
out of here all right coming up bare
knuckle fist fights breaking out in a
democratic City over Biden's border
crisis hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now